und über das treffen heute im kanzleramt
spreche ich mit michael hüther direktor
des arbeitgebernahen instituts der
deutschen wirtschaft iw schönen guten
tag
das treffen heute zwischen wirtschaft
und gewerkschaften im kanzleramt das
soll ja erst mal gar keine ergebnissen
ergebnisse bringen keine konkreten
liebezeit hatte denn mehr allzu viel
zeit haben wir nicht bemerken ja die
gesamtwirtschaftliche lage wird
unsicherer und der große elefant im raum
ist ein möglichst gas-embargo seitens
der russen aber es ist ganz wichtig dass
dieses treffen stattfindet denn zunächst
einmal geht es darum eine gemeinsame
bewertung der lage vorzunehmen das kann
man nicht hoch genug schätzen denn es
gibt unterschiedliche ausgangs
bewertungen es gibt unterschiedliche
sichten auf den jeweils anderen akteurs
ist ja nicht nur der staat dabei ist es
auch die bundesbank dabei das heißt die
geld vertretung der geldpolitik auf
deutscher ebene wenn man so will und das
zusammenzuführen heute überhaupt mal im
bild zu bekommen ist glaube ich sehr
wichtig denn dann kann man auch zu
gemeinsamen überlegungen handeln dann
schauen wir mal auf die verschiedenen
aspekte es gibt einmal das thema
inflation es gibt extrem hohe preise
momentan eine idee richtung
gewerkschaften und arbeitgeber aus dem
kanzleramt vor dem treffen heute war
einmalzahlungen statt hoher
tarifabschlüsse was sagen sie dazu man
muss ja sehen die grundlinie der
lohnpolitik ist die produktivitäts
orientierung das heißt das was an
leistungssteigerungen jahr möglich ist
das liegt natürlich weit niedriger als
die inflation die inflation aber wenn
sie erleben ist ja kein dauer phänomen
wir gehen davon aus nächstes jahr auch
die ezb nur noch dreieinhalb prozent
also es geht deutlich zurück das sollte
man nicht die tabellen einbauen und
dafür ist ergänzend dann eine
einmalzahlung in sein gesamt-paket
attraktiv das ist auch nicht neu das ist
auch schon verschiedentlich gemacht
worden aber es gibt durchaus menschen
die sagen das hilft nicht die inflation
ist gerade hoch das hilft den leuten
nicht langfristig wenn wir jetzt eine
einmalzahlung haben beispielsweise die
spd chefin
hat sich heute klar dafür ausgesprochen
höhere tarifabschlüsse zu haben was
übersieht sie da vielleicht eine höhere
tarifabschlüsse machen dann heißt das ja
wohl in höhe der inflationsrate dann
überwälzen wie die preise noch einmal
ins system und dann ist es nicht mehr
nur ein inflations import sondern wir
haben in der breite über die lohnpolitik
dann ein inflationsschub der auch weiter
in das nächste jahr hinein trägt und das
ist immer das was man vermeiden will
eine sogenannte low preis spirale und
deswegen durchaus etwas tun mit
einmalzahlung wenn die denn dann steuer
sozial beitragsfrei wären wären sie
brutto für netto das gibt ein
interessantes gesamtpaket so dass die
eigentliche tariferhöhung sich deutlich
niedriger bemessen kann und man kann die
am nächsten jahr schauen ob man dann
noch mal eine sonderzahlung macht und
dem rechnung passiert man sehen ob sich
die gewerkschaften darauf einlassen
gucken wir auf den anderen punkt auf den
gaspreisen ich will sorgen macht sich
die industrie da tatsächlich bald nicht
mehr genug zu haben ja es geht nicht
wirklich den preis gibt die menge sie
haben genug zu haben denn wenn die
russen abstellen und wenn nord stream 1
dann nach der erwartung nicht mehr in
die lieferung geht haben wir ein großes
problem dann kommen wir noch bis in den
herbst und wir müssen feststellen in
vielen produktionen können wir das nicht
einfach ersetzen das wird ja für
bestimmte wärmeproduktion genutzt aber
auch für bestimmte produktion wie dünger
da brauche ich gas als beigabe und das
aus den anderen weltmärkten zu ziehen
ist halt nicht so einfach das muss über
schiffe transportiert werden da müssen
wir allen transformationen ist es
deutlich teurer und wir haben die mengen
so schnell nicht das ist das eigentliche
problem das heißt was muss passieren was
muss passieren dass alle sowieso sparen
ganz klar also auch die unternehmen
müssen schauen wo können sie gas
ersetzen das findet auch statt weil
jeder weiß was es bedeutet aber wir
müssen auch schauen dass wir als private
haushalte im herbst wenn wieder die
heizung angestellt ist vielleicht etwas
zurückhaltender sind der staat kann
etwas in seinen verwaltungseinrichtungen
tun also alle können etwas tun bis wir
dann wieder enorm etwas normaler lage
haben brauche es zusätzliche
anreizmodelle oder vielleicht sogar
staatlich verordnete sparen mehr
staatlich verordnetes sparen ist bei
privaten haushalt schwierig muss die
rheiner bei ihnen zu hause vorbei kommen
und sicher thermostat anschauen und wir
können auch nicht einfach gas runter
drehen weil wenn sie das nicht wenn sie
das mal gemacht haben und dann wieder
hochdrehen fliegen die möglicherweise
wenn ich über die ventile offen sind
auch die haushalte um die ohren das
wollen wir sicher nicht also müssen wir
es gemeinsam begreifen als eine
herausforderung da hilfen anreize nicht
viel wir müssen klar machen es betrifft
alle in diesem land also sie setzen klar
darauf dass die leute von sich aus da
weniger verbrauchen ja also
verantwortung muss jeder schon zeigen
denn jetzt noch mal ein anreiz obendrauf
man kann sagen man zahlt eine prämie
aber das finde ich eine billige mitnahme
über mehr überlegung also insofern
sollten auch klar adressiert werden bei
fern damit kann man zum beispiel ja auch
zentral etwas weniger temperatur
eingeben das müssen alle gemeinsam
wissen sagt michael hüther direktor des
instituts der deutschen wirtschaft iw
vielen dank fürs internet sehr gerne